you've obviously been a millionaire for
a long time what is a lesson about money
that you've learned that you would like
to try to you know kind of spread
because a lot of people don't understand
just financial literacy in general
especially especially when you get that
much money you know what i'm saying
what's something that you had to kind of
learn the hardware or some game you
could give it's just about financial
sure for sure man
every i think um
like one would say find people you can
trust but then you even look at some of
the instances the incidents that's
happening with some pros where
like these uh some people took
buckets of money
you know so i was like how do you find
somebody you trust you're working with
the smartest people in suits right so
but
find somebody you trust but also do your
own diligence if you can i mean if you
can pay some of your own bills do it
just start
you know if you have said you're a first
round pick or like a new artist
you know okay maybe
you know what you're going to be making
100 million 200 300 400 500 million
because this is happening but i think in
the beginning stages you should be doing
a lot of it on your own
you should know something about your
taxes know something about bill pay you
know you should know something about
diversifying your portfolio
you know sometimes we have so much cash
sitting in the bank it's like
we're not going to spend all this cash
today or you will spend it but certainly
on the wrong things right but you can
actually take a chunk of that and put it
to work you're not going to spend you
know 100 million yeah go buy a apartment
building or
do you know i feel like a lot of young
nba players there's a lot of people who
kind of
you know financially
are predatory towards some of these
young athletes and artists like when it
comes to
did you ever have anyone try to get in
your pockets or try to mismanage your
situation i had good people man i think
i had good people around me um i'm very
um independent
so for me
um i always wanted to do my own thing
start my own management company i wanted
my own shoes you know i mean so
but you know i think um you know for the
most part
you know i think it's a huge opportunity
i mean these athletes are corporations
it's like new corporations and within a
day
you you you mean a great return on our
you know company oh you're making two
million dollars a year you're like oh i
made two million of [ __ ] right that's
great
these guys is making 50 million 10 mil
20 mil
like that's a corporation
some real [ __ ] man that is that is
literally a corporation
yeah in a year think about that yeah
there's some james harden's about to opt
into 47 million dollars i'm like jesus
christ christ
what was your biggest year like that you
had in the nba as far as just
the most i've made was 40. i made 40
twice wow but you know
my my skill level would request more but
because i was getting so much trouble
every time it was time to get more
or max you got 240 40 million dollar
contracts yeah wow so i always got the
minimum
yeah you i mean yeah but it was i'm
grateful yeah i'm grateful hell yeah i'm
not like when i when i got drafted i i
work in a circuit city like i i should
shout out to circuit city i never i got
i applied for a job at circuit city when
i got drafted you know what i'm saying
so i was never like
needed a lot okay i've never had like a
bentley i've never had a rose you know
what i'm saying um
but so for me i was i was fortunate
enough to be like that type person
but i also wish like i would have never
made those mistakes because i it was
times where teams said we gonna match
you out